vous dites mes oreilles entendent pour
la première fois et mon corps se mettait
à bouger d'une façon différente c'est
une véritable révélation pour vous cette
musique voici Maurice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Béjard
bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir Maurice Béjard c'est pas
pour critiquer mais sans le collant ça
le fait moins il y a longtemps vous
savez il y a très très longtemps alors
Maurice Béjard vous avez déclaré je
supporte mal ce qui m'est arrivé je suis
devenu une espèce de Monument Historique
qu'on visite une tour penchée de Pise
non c'est vrai que des fois on a besoin
d'être comme tout le monde de pas être
séparé des autres mais heureusement dans
le travail c'est quelque chose de très
honnête dans le travail c'est un travail
physique comme les sportifs comme les
footballeurs et donc il y a une chose
qui va qui nous resserre avec les autres
peut dire que vous avez une influence
prépondérante sur l'histoire du balai au
20e siècle en le sortant des des
chapelles élitistes et en l'apportant au
grand public vous êtes le premier à
avoir fait quitter l'opéra au balai vous
avez jouer dans dans dans des cirques
dans des arènes dans des Palais des
Sport sport dans le monde il y a pas un
Palais des Sport pas été Amérique Asie
Chine non oui c'est que maintenant ça a
l'air très très habituel de de de voir
des balais ailleurs que dans des opéra
mais à l'époque où vous l'avez fait
c'était cétait un scandale et puis les
gens disaient non pourquoi le balai là
il y aura personne et c'est pas VI les
gens venaient je crois que c'est très
important de se rendre compte que la
danse est un art actuel est un art
moderne c'est l'art de la jeunesse et
vous avez contribué à sortir le le
ballet de son placard un peu vous l'z
connaître le placard
ou le placard C l'OP Gard
merci je cétait arrivé à faire respirer
à faire respirer j'ai une chance énorme
je travaille avec des jeunes ils
viennent ils ont 16 ans ils rentrent à
l'école je les vois et tout ce qu'ils me
disent j'apprends parce qu' il croi
qu'ils vont apprendre mais c'est pas
vrai c'est moi qui apprends parce que
j'apprends au fur à mesure et ça fait
qu' des temps avec eux je vois le monde
évolué et je vois pas que je vieillis je
me rends pas compte que je vieillis
parce que je vois leur tête pas la
bienenne vous dites votre âge Maurice
oui 77 ouais je suis d en 27 ouais 1er
janvier à Marseille 1er janvier à
Marseille oui comment tu sais il est
bien renseigné mais je lis je me
documente je m'intéresse aux entrechats
au au Tirat sacré charlem mais oui non
ça c'était avant ah c'est fini ça c'est
fini maintenant bien alors donc vous
fêtez les 50 ans de votre compagnie vous
sillonnez l'Europe le 26 vous labourez
l'Europe on peut même direour le 26 et
27 novembre vous êtes au Zénit de Lille
le 26 mai jusqu'au 5 juin vous êtes au
Palais des Sports de Paris avec un best
off
euh vous êtes plus fatigué par les 77
ans vous parlez 50 ans de direction de
compagnie mais je me rends pas compte
parce que 50 ans de direction de
compagnie mais attention j'ai dansé à 18
ans ouis je suis parti en Angleterre
j'ai travaillé pendant un an et demi en
Angleterre là je suis parti en Suède à
18 ans vous avez quitté votre province
bien décidé à conqu Paris
d'accord on change de chanteur d'cord
mais pas Paris du tout parce que c'est
très curieux parce que Marseille c'était
mon lieu arrivé à Paris j'étais à
l'étranger non je n'ai rien alors je
Allis à Londres j'étais à l'étranger je
suis Allis à Stockholm j'étais à
l'étranger et finalement euh je me suis
rendu compte que ma patrie euh c'était
un peu partout un peu partout alors
votre vrai nom c'est berger vous avez
pris Béjard en fait à cause d'Armand
Béjard la la la femme de Molière voilà
vous êtes né à Marseille père philosophe
très fameux Gaston Berger c'est une
c'est pas bâton de berger non non
ohon oh là là là là là là Gaston mer je
fa ça en portepièce hein parce que c'est
pas préparé et donc votre famille c'est
une famille de militaire établie à
Saint-Louis du Sénégal et votre
arrière-g-mère était noire oui Fatou
Diagne voilà Fatou Diagne et quand je
vais au Sénégal enfin quand j'allais le
président saingor est plus là il a
retrouvé toutes les archives de la
famille et il a vu qu'il était fatouagne
où elle habitait quand ça s'est passé
une famille de Saint-Louis ouais
renez-moi au pays du soleil vous avez un
petit a pas tellement de soleil il y a
beaucoup de vent il y a un climat assez
dur vous avez un petit bout d'Afrique à
l'intérieur de vous quoi ben je crois
que lorsque j'ai créé le sacre du
printempsou le président saor m'a dit tu
vois tu aurais pas eu une goutte de sang
noir tu aurais raté ce balai ouais et je
crois que c'est c'est vrai parce que
lorsque j'arrive là-bas la musique les
gens je sens quelque chose en communauté
qui m'apporte beaucoup ouais alors la
musique a été présente très tôt dans
dans votre vie Maurice beéjard vers
l'âge de 89 ans vous commencez à jouer
l'ouverture de tanuser mais la fermeture
beaucoup plus tard sur un pian mécanique
justement dans une vitrine sur un piano
mécanique chez votre grand-mère qui
était brocanteuse oui ouais oui à cette
époque vous voyez des gà en haut de
laaffiche
euh j'ai pas tellement fait attention à
l'affiche vous
savez alors après la guerre vous êtes
intéressé par le théâtre vous êtes
intéressé par la littérature allemande
mais finalement les médecins vous
conseillent la danse parce que vous avez
des problèmes de dos et et vous débutez
dans la danse d'abord à à Marseille
ensuite à Paris alors là vous dansez
auprès de Jenine Charara de de de Roland
Petit et en 1953 vous fondez votre
première compagnie Les Bala de l'étoile
voilà mais la la vraie révolution en
fait ça sera votre rencontre avec
pierrehenri et Pierre Cheffer les
pionniers de la musique électroque CIT
fantastique parce que cette musique
c'était la fin du monde c'est un monde
au notre monde on se rend pas compte que
c'était en 55 entendre les sons
qui venaient alors il avaient pas encore
les bandes sonores ouais il
travaillaient avec des disques comme on
fait maintenant dans les boîtes voyez
ils avaient trois quatre disques et il
tourn en même temps et il renregistrai
la musique et c'était fantastique mais
c'est les inventeurs de la musique
électroacoustique quoi tout simplement
absolument pierrehenri a fait des choses
entends dans C boîtes à la mode des fois
ouais c'est plaisir des Moder
ça donc là votre univers musical
s'écroule complètement quoi oui c'est
que j'ai j'ai rentendu avant j'entendais
pas je connaissais Wagner Chopin et là
j'ai entendu la musique parce que ce
sont décapé tout ce sont arraché tout et
tout d'un coup deux notes de Mozart
redevenaient un miracle ouais ça m'a
beaucoup aider vous dites mes oreilles
entendaient pour la première fois et mon
corps se mettait à bouger d'une façon
différente c'est une véritable
révélation pour vous cette musique c'est
vrai bon j'ai jamais été un grand
danseur j'étais un danseur comme ça vous
étiz là pour V sa Mace c'est vrai
comment vous le savezvous vous avez
commencé vous étiez en verre vous étiez
il était emmailloté comme un verre he
comme un verre de terre une chenille et
oui et il faisait des faisz des sauts
oui très beau mec très bel homme vous
étiez vous êtes un très bel homme mais
franchement la
vérité il y a quelque c'est un aigle il
y a quelque chose je me souviens de lui
moii mê il a envie de baiser non arrête
vrai
aussi les deux sont vrais chant beaucoup
d'allure les deux sont vrais alors vous
avez eu un grand choc avec la musique
électroacoustique et pourtant
aujourd'hui vous dites que la musique
techno vous la trouvez nazi vous dites
quand vous l'entendez vous avez
l'impression d'entendre les le le pas de
des soldats allemand le pas des bottes
dans les rues de Marseille parce que
j'aime la musique électronique avec une
certaine subtilité mais le boum boum
boum boum c'est vrai que je l' entendu
dans les r de Marseille quand les nazis
passaient là c'était B bom bom bom et
parfois ça m'agace un peu parce que la
techno est un mode qui très riche et
très nouveau et très formidable mais
parfois se limite à un rythme très
primaire et ça c'est dommage ti ce que
les jeunes prennent pour une nouvelle
liberté pour vous c'est un nouvel
endoctrinement d'une certaine façou ABS
ouais alors vous avez reçu une formation
catholique très très forte hein pendant
12 ans vous étz là à la messe tous les
matins et puis en
1973 alors vous êtes converti à l'islam
enfin disons plutôt au soufisme pourquoi
j'aime pas le mot converti voyez
converti ça veut dire dier le passé et
dire tout ça ça vaut rien on va ailleurs
ça veut dire que j'ai fait un chemin je
suis quelqu'un qui était croyant
toujours très très croyant j'étais élevé
dans une religion catholique très
stricte et qui m'a beaucoup apporté que
j'ai aimé que j'aime encore et puis j'ai
découvert d'autres formes de pensée j'ai
beaucoup travaillé au Japon j'ai eu un
maître zen et j'ai fait beaucoup d'arts
martiaux voyez qui m'a formé le corps
différemment et puis ensuite j'ai
rencontré un un maître iranien ouais
était un homme extraordinaire et j'ai
travaillé avec lui en profondeur et m'a
aidé à trouver un chemin qui continue
mais c'est pas une négation du passé
c'est une évolution un syncrétisme
peut-être vous êtes influençable
très peut-être c'est le dernier qui
cause qui a raison et le bouddhisme et
franchement c'est pas bien le bouddhisme
le bhisme c'est le Japon çai alors en
fait votre seule vraie religion c'est la
danse vous dites si la danse ne conserve
pas une parcelle de sacré ce n'est plus
de la danse c'est vrai ou j'y crois
profondément ou profondément d'ailleurs
toutes les traditions autent
asiatique américaine du Sud ou africaine
la religion et la danse sont lié sont
lié et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inard tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu